Can you trust zonked videos to answer
this question will first explain how we
research them and then talk
a bit about paths, videos,
and where we want to
achieve with the channel.
Making a cause out video always begins
with a question or an issue. For example,
after our meat video,
many viewers asked about the
health effects of meat on humans.
We had no idea and we're pretty curious
too, so we just decided to work on it.
The first step is research.
We start by looking for
books and scientific papers
to get an overview and just
read a lot.
The plan is to find a story worth telling.
Is there something surprising to learn?
Is there a larger context or a new
perspective or will it be an overview or
introduction?
Once we have the first readable version,
we reached out to experts or scientists
and ask them to fact check and correct
us.
Often enough,
they find a floor or pointers in the
direction of contradictory research.
At this point, many scripts
dime. If our idea does hold up,
we continue working on this.
This process can take weeks or months.
Our loneliness script, for example,
took over a year and a half to finish.
The hardest part is being brief.
Well, not simplifying too much.
It's much easier to write a
long scripts that are short one.
When we're finally done,
we do another round of research and
show the Strip two experts. Again, IDD,
different ones than the ones we talked
to at the beginning of the process.
When we express an opinion,
we'd market as such.
That's not saying that we don't
draw conclusions from the research.
Homeopathy does not work and meat
is really bad for the planet.
Climate change is real, but organic
food is not a good way of solving it.
If the facts clearly support a conclusion,
it's okay to present it as such.
Of course,
we can't always make everybody happy.
People who know a lot about
a topic sometimes get annoyed
if we don't mention an
aspect they think is crucial or
when we omit technical terms.
This is more or less unsolvable because
of the nature of our videos and scripts
have around 1,300 words, so there's
always some degree of simplification.
You will always find the list of our
research and sources and further reading
material in the video description.
Just citing sources doesn't make your work
accurate or your research good though,
so we encourage you to use our sources
document as a starting point to look at
the topic yourself and learn more.
But it would be dishonest to say
that we've always worked this way.
Some older videos don't live up to
the standards we set ourselves today.
The two that annoy us the most are
the refugee and addiction videos.
In both of them, we didn't try to
present a balanced perspective,
but instead chose a taken ran with it.
The refugee video was made with a deep
feeling of angry frustration about the
world and the high point
of the 2015 refugee crisis.
While we argued over quotas, dead
children washed ashore and our coastlines.
The stripped was resin on one Sunday
afternoon and illustrated and animated
within a week. It was exhausting,
stressful and frustrating.
We still believe it was the right
thing for European countries to help,
but it was absolutely
unnecessary to be toxic about it.
We insulted people and brushed away
their concerns about real and profound
challenges.
The video was divisive and emotional at
a time when the debate needed a calm and
clear overview.
The addiction video was based on only
one source that has amassed a lot of
criticism over the years and unfortunately
we did not reach out to scientists or
do extra research on the papers that
were the basis for the videos thesis.
That addiction is purely psychological
and based on the life circumstances of
the individual.
This dance is still held by a number of
addiction professionals and we're not
saying it's wrong,
but a lot of others disagree and it's
not correct to presented as the truth.
Addiction is far from solved.
An hour video should have reflected
that instead of taking one side,
we simplified an idea so much that it
made a great story but became distorting.
Both videos were made over the span of
two months and they're two of our most
successful videos. To date, we had
found a formula that really works,
but we never made anything like them
again and have been discussing how to deal
with them for a long
time and it doesn't help.
The both videos are loved by many people.
We want to be proud of our work and
these two videos don't make us proud.
So today we deleted them.
It will purge them from the Internet,
but that's not the goal. Anyway.
Feel free to upload them elsewhere.
We're working on a new addiction video
that will take a look at the chemical and
psychological causes.
We'll take our sweet time with it,
so please have patience. The refugee
video is not up to date anymore,
so we will not renew it.
We're also going through our
older videos to add sources,
further reading and comments in
the next few months. Nowadays,
rather than trusting in
mainstream institutions,
we often look at creators on the
Internet for reliable information.
We rely on the fact that they're careful
and rigorous and not led by monetary
incentives,
and we expect them to acknowledge mistakes
in public and work to minimize them.
So this is what we're going to do.
Trust is not a thing you are
in once and then keep forever.
You have to constantly work for it.
So can you trust courts because aren't
you can trust that every video we make is
30 research to and approved
by different experts.
You can trust that we know that we have
biases and we try to overcome them.
We want to move coats cause aren't
further towards the trustworthy end of the
spectrum.
The world is too complex for simple
answers and we don't want to be the ones
giving them. Making these videos over
the last six years has been quite a ride.
Now we're very grateful for us.
We hope you'll be with us for the next
few years to and join us on our journey
to figure out what this universe
and life stuff is all about.
Thank you for watching.
Okay.